6 30 here on a monday morning we are
following breaking news another deadly
hit and run on our roads
it happened overnight a busy stretch of
flamingo roads still closed at the 6 30
hour hector mejia has been live there on
scene all morning long he joins us now
with the latest good morning hector
good morning and the lanes right behind
me those lanes of flamingo were closed
for several hours overnight but they
just reopened a few minutes ago actually
about 30 minutes ago after police were
investigating a deadly hit-and-run crash
along those lanes they tell us the crash
happened around one o'clock this morning
metro police say a man was crossing
flamingo in front of desert springs
hospital when he was hit by white
colored mercedes
police say the driver took off it's not
clear which direction that driver went
police right now are trying to find
surveillance video from nearby
businesses and they hope that video
shows the car
either before or after the crash the
pedestrian was rushed to sunrise
hospital but died shortly after arriving
and again the suspect vehicle is a white
colored mercedes
likely with front end damage if you know
anything anything
police are asking you to dial a 9-1-1
and metro police also say
this year they are dealing with a spike
and deadly hit and run crashes
and again the lanes just reopened here
just about 30 minutes ago
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now